[Music]
Vanessa bryan pease tribute to her
daughter Gianna on what would have been
her 14th birthday on Friday the 37 year
old posted this gorgeous pic of her
sweet baby girl smiling and wished her a
happy birthday in the caption quote
mommy loves you more than I can ever
show you you are part of my soul forever
I miss you so much every day Vanessa
went on to write quote I wish I could
wake up and have you here with me I miss
your smile your hugs and your giggles I
miss everything about you Gigi I love
you so much
soon after the mom before posted a
series of photos with a caption
encouraging people to wear red in honor
of her late daughter's birthday vanessa
explains that gigi loved to wear a red
bow in all of her school pictures the
color of love in life she writes in part
quote please consider wearing red
caption an act of kindness or show how
you will play Gigi's way since she
always gave everything she did her all
and led with kindness Gigi and Vanessa's
husband basketball great Kobe Bryant
lost their lives along with seven others
in a January helicopter crash
[Applause]
they were in route to a basketball
tournament at Kobe's Mamba Academy thank
you so much for honoring my GG been
selecting her to be an honorary draft
pick this year it would have been a
dream come true for her last month the
WNBA made Gigi an honorary draft pick
the youngest ever she worked tirelessly
every single day she wanted to be one of
the greatest athletes of all time just
like her daddy so thank you thank you
for honoring my little girl
despite the unimaginable pain of losing
her husband and Gigi vanessa has managed
to stay strong for her three daughters
17 year old Natalia three year old
Bianca and nine month old Capri the wife
of the late NBA star shared beautiful
photos of her and her daughter
celebrating their first Easter without
Kobe and Gigi she even posted this
adorable video of Bianca and Capri
enjoying some Easter treats back in
February a source close to the family
told ET that Vanessa knows the grieving
process will be long and hard the source
went on to say that she is overwhelmed
with the outpouring of love her and her
family received
you